[Aplausos]
quando terminou a festa de cinco anos da
minha filha mais nova
meu filho mais velho hotel de 12
perguntou pra ela caia quem os seus
amigos não veio na sua festa de
aniversário
ela pensou e respondeu a um nelson
mandela
desde que ela e seus irmãos nasceram eu
penso e me preocupo no mundo que eu vou
deixar pra eles quando não estiver mais
aqui
e essa preocupação e esse pensamento
chegaram junto com o chamado da minha
alma que eu vou dizer para vocês qual é
eu vim de uma família que sempre lutou
muito e eu tenho dois irmãos
a minha mãe era professora da febem eu
convivi diariamente com 150 meninos
órfãos
hoje ela é aposentada bela e perder a
capacidade de amar de cuidar e de
compartilhar meu pai ele sempre foi
vendedor
hoje ele é empresário ele vem de sacos
de lixos reforçados e produtos para
festas descartáveis
ele vende a domicílio e na frente dos
melhores supermercados de ribeirão
cidade onde eu nasci cidade também onde
tem uma rodoviária bem grande e onde meu
pai dormiu várias vezes dele perder a
capacidade de acreditar que está tudo
bem que a vida vale a pena ea capacidade
da esperança com os dois
eu aprendi a lutar ea nunca desistir
então vim pra são paulo aqui em são
paulo eu fui babá foi recepcionista
vendedor a monitora de festa infantil
foi quase professora quase biomédica me
formei em artes cênicas e fui quase
famosa e fiz uma peça de teatro com
gente muito querido e muito famosa
eu fiz duas novelas que pouquíssimas
pessoas se lembram mas quem fez a novela
me casei três vezes me separei as três
mas eu nunca desistir de amar e nunca
desistir do amor e nunca desistir de
deixar o mundo melhor pra gaia por levi
e protel e nunca desistir dê a cada dia
me tornar uma pessoa melhor
enquanto tudo isso acontecia o chamado
da minha alma insistia em falar dentro
de mim
seja você tenha coragem de dizer ao
mundo quem você é
foi então que no dia 5 de junho de 2013
eu convenci dez amigos porque se você
tem um sonho além de você mais uma
pessoa tem que acreditar nele
no meu caso 10 acreditaram depois de
vinte falar que eu estava louca ea gente
foi às ruas neste dia registrar o que eu
já fazia sem contar pra ninguém
ajudar as pessoas nesse dia eu levei
flores e me oferecia desconhecidos
olá meu nome é renata que eu posso fazer
por você agora
então nesse dia eu ouvi histórias
eu carreguei sacola de compras pesadas
eu dei muitos abraços
comprei vassoura e varre o chão
eu puxei um carrinho de 100 quilos de
sucata e fiz uma festa por uma moça que
estava sozinha no dia de seu aniversário
chamada renata renata o meu nome eu já
tive sozinha em vários aniversários meus
e poder compartilhar com ela oferecer
pra ela uma festa numa praça rodeada de
amigos
foi um resgate para mim naquele dia eu
fiz jus ao significado do nosso nome
renascida naquele dia eu me encaixei com
o universo porque todo mundo aqui tem o
seu encaixe com ele
e quando esse encaixe acontece você
fique em paz à sua alma brilha e o mundo
te vê em uma jornada de muitas dores em
uma jornada de muitos aprendizados
às vezes assustadores sem nenhum
patrocínio nasceu o instituto a nossa
jornada que hoje a gente já chegou em 80
cidades brasileiras em seis países
já ajudamos mais de duas mil pessoas com
a pergunta o que eu posso fazer por você
agora somos gente cuidando de gente
o adriano passou no vestibular para
medicina em salvador estudando em
apostilas de cursinhos usados que nós
mudamos pra ele
a higiene resgatamos ela da terrível
guerra do congo trouxemos para o brasil
alimentamos com 6 mil livros à
biblioteca de mariana minas gerais
fizemos da sória uma rainha
a regina só queria uma amiga pra
conversar a gente foi almoçar e eu
ganhei uma grande amiga
o thiago é um garoto humilde com
síndrome de down sonhava em conhecer a
disney
o tenor queria ver o mar
adriana queria um vestido de 15 anos
o jayme morador de rua ele queria uma
máquina de costura toalhas linha para
libor da e ele sai das ruas
a dona ana o sonho dela passear no
ibirapuera ela precisava de uma perna
nova o setor refugiados lado quênia eles
têm sonhos e agentes realiza a delza a
deusa procurar a mãe dela por 20 anos ea
gente encontrou em 48 horas
foram com essas pessoas e outras tantas
que eu entendi para deixar um mundo
melhor
a gente precisa deixar pessoas melhores
nesse mundo a começar por mim e eu quero
ser uma pessoa melhor
foram com essas histórias e outras
tantas que eu resgato as minhas
histórias e os em caixa aqui dentro
e como é que eu fiz tudo isso já que
estou longe de ser uma pessoa rica e
todo mês eu tenho que escolher a conta
que eu vou pagar a conta que vai ter que
esperar
eu fiz isso conectando as pessoas
eu fiz isso compartilhando as minhas
histórias sendo forte e fez isso
agradecendo eu agradeço todas as pessoas
que estão do meu lado me ajudando nessa
caminhada porque eu sou uma pessoa comum
eu sou exatamente como todo mundo mas eu
tenho pessoas do meu lado que me ajudam
que estão junto comigo então se você
também que esta é uma pessoa melhor
série de pessoas melhores do que você
que te ajudem nessa caminhada na
caminhada de iluminar nossa sombra
porque a gente tem muito mais medo da
nossa luz
a gente não conhece do que da nossa
sombra que a nossa velha conhecida
eu não sou um exemplo pra ninguém eu não
quero ser um exemplo pra ninguém
gostaria de ser uma inspiração porque
você também pode fazer alguma coisa por
alguém
é só você olhar no olho de quem tinha
olha e perguntar o que eu posso fazer
por você agora
e quando você fizer essa pergunta é a
pessoa te responder
faça por você não por ela que se você
fizer por ela você vai julgá la
agora quando a gente faz algo
profundamente pela gente
a gente faz profundamente por ela acesse
a nelo sentimento de gratidão e reacende
a sua luz e isso nos torna um desse
jeito tudo o que é seu
vai dar um jeito de chegar até você
porque quando a gente cuida do outro
universo dá um jeito de cuidar da gente
muitas vezes
me sinto impotente diante da dor diante
da dor das pessoas que eu amo
gente da minha própria dor então digo a
vocês
diante das a dor que vocês também vão
sentir ame am me ama enquanto puder amar
porque o amor é a única força que
transforma o destino e que sarah todas
as feridas e nesse destino você pode ser
um suspiro na vida de alguém eu te
desejo o teu encaixe com o universo que
diante da dúvida que você lute para
encontrar a certeza de que nunca nunca
nunca desista de amar e de acreditar que
tá tudo bem e eu o que eu posso fazer
por você agora